vamos a rascar le un poco más al tema de
las transformaciones de lorentz y en
particular vamos a poner algunos números
aquí para que nos familiaricemos con su
manipulación y ya luego vamos a poder
tener más intuición sobre cómo se
comportan estas transformaciones así que
vamos a suponer como siempre que la
velocidad de la nave de mi amiga es la
mitad de la velocidad de la luz verdad
entonces aquí la velocidad relativa de
mi amiga será 0.5 por la velocidad de la
luz verdad y por supuesto se está
moviendo en la dirección positiva del
eje x verdad entonces aquí tenemos los
diagramas de espacio-tiempo verdad y
vemos que en efecto coinciden en el
origen muy bien así que fijémonos ahora
en este evento este evento que que ya
habíamos incluso trabajado en vídeos
pasados verdad y que vamos a suponer que
en mi marco de referencia tengan las
siguientes coordenadas vamos a suponer
por ejemplo que la coordenada x
un metro verdad vamos a suponer que la
coordenada x sea un metro y vamos a
suponer que la coordenada 7 también sea
un metro y de hecho ya hemos ya hemos
dicho verdad que podemos pensar esto
como un metro luz es decir el tiempo que
tarda la luz en recorrer un metro verdad
entonces aquí este evento tendrá las
coordenadas 1,1 verdad ahora con base en
esto trata de pensar cuáles serían las
coordenadas en el otro marco de
referencia en x prima y 7 prima verdad
que sería el marco de referencia de mi
amiga verdad entonces te invito a que
hagas una pausa y trates de deducir cuál
sería el valor de estos en términos de
las transformaciones de lawrence por
supuesto tendrás que calcular el factor
de lawrence este esta variable beta
verdad y sustituir
entonces suponiendo que ya hiciste esto
tú solito vamos a tratar de hacerlo
ahora todos juntos y primero vamos a
calcular el valor de beta muy bien
entonces beta beta por como lo definimos
sería la velocidad relativa dividida
entre la velocidad de la luz pero la
velocidad relativa es 0.5 c y la
velocidad de la luz es justamente ser
verdad entonces uno puede pensar a beta
como como la fracción de la velocidad de
la luz a la que viaja la persona en mi
marco de referencia verdad esa sería una
interpretación de beta entonces aquí
nuestras constantes de verdad la
velocidad de la luz se cancelan y
simplemente nos queda que beta es 0.5
muy bien entonces ahora con esto ya
podemos calcular el factor de lawrence
es decir la variable gamma verdad gamma
simplemente sería 1 dividido entre
a raíz cuadrada de 1 - beta cuadrada que
en este caso es 0.5 al cuadrado y que si
nosotros sustituimos esto sería
simplemente 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de
uno menos 0.5 al cuadrado pero 0.5 al
cuadrado es 0.25 y uno menos 0.25 sería
0.75 muy bien entonces vamos a tratar de
calcular este valor así que vamos a
sacar la calculadora entonces tendremos
0.75 vamos a obtener la raíz cuadrada es
0.86 62 y un montón de números más y
ahora vamos a obtener el recíproco muy
bien el recíproco de eso es 1 punto
vamos vamos a dejarlo simplemente como
1.15 muy bien entonces esto es el factor
de laurent es aproximadamente 1 punto
muy bien ahí tenemos el factor del
ourense entonces ahora con esto ya
podemos calcular la coordenada x prima y
la coordenada 7 prima verdad entonces x
prima será igual al factor de lawrence
que es 1 1.15 1.15 multiplica a la
coordenada 7 perdón es la coordenada xy
estaba yendo al otro es uno menos beta
que en este caso es 0.5 que multiplica a
la coordenada 7 verdad por la coordenada
7 es uno muy bien ahí tenemos cómo
calcular x prima y ahora para calcular 7
prima
esto será nuevamente el factor de
lawrence el factor de laurent que es
1.15 que multiplica a ahora sí 7 que es
uno menos la beta que es 0.5 que
multiplica a x que en este caso es 1
entonces aquí puedes observar muy
en la simetría que tenemos verdad
entonces 1 menos 0.5 en este caso será
0.5 verdad esto es 0.5 y 1 menos 0.5
también será 0.5 entonces si nos damos
cuenta ambas coordenadas simplemente se
van a calcular al multiplicar 1.15 por
0.5 0.5 verdad entonces vamos a ver esto
a que es aproximadamente verdad todo
esto
todo esto es aproximado verdad porque el
valor de gamma lo estamos aproximando
muy bien entonces aquí tenemos ya el
valor del factor de lawrence y
simplemente lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar por 0.5 y eso nos da 0.5 o
77 vamos a redondear lo como 0.58
entonces tanto x prima como 7 prima es
0.58
punto 58 es decir si nos regresamos aquí
a nuestro diagrama de espacio-tiempo
nuestra coordenada equis prima será será
aproximadamente aproximadamente 0.58 y
la coordenada act prima también será
aproximadamente 0.58 y recordemos que
todo esto está dado en metros verdad
aquí son metros y acá también son metros
muy bien entonces si si regresamos y
garza a mi dibujo en donde yo estaba a
la deriva en el espacio verdad
recordemos que yo tenía aquí una
linterna desde el cual disparaba yo un
fotón en de igual a cero en el tiempo te
igual a cero y en y en el lugar x igual
a cero entonces disparamos el fotón de
mi linterna y nosotros podemos dibujar
su trayectoria en el diagrama de
espacio-tiempo verdad básicamente será
esta recta que tiene un ángulo de 45
grados respecto al eje verdad
entonces ya ya ya que tenemos eso ahora
podemos ver cuáles son las coordenadas
de ese mismo punto pero en el marco de
referencia de mi amiga verdad entonces
en realidad cuando yo digo que el fotón
ha recorrido un metro y un metro luz de
tiempo verdad digamos ha pasado digamos
un metro luz de tiempo entonces desde el
marco de referencia de mi amiga da ella
podría decir no no no no no eso eso no
ocurre en realidad eso ocurre a 0.58
metros luz desde que pasó sobre de mi
verdad y además ocurrió a 0.58 metros en
la dirección positiva del eje x verdad
así que está ocurriendo algo muy pero
muy interesante y te invito a que
pienses sobre lo que realmente está
pasando en estas distintas partes de las
transformaciones de lawrence todo esto
es bastante interesante pero pero
pensemos que ocurre por ejemplo con el
factor de lawrence por ejemplo qué
pasaría si la velocidad relativa
es muy muy pequeña es decir si esta
velocidad es casi cero
bueno pues podríamos ver que beta en
efecto también sería casi cero verdad y
entonces el factor de lawrence sería
aproximadamente 1 verdad cuando la
velocidad relativa es muy pequeña por
otro lado qué pasaría si la velocidad
relativa va aumentando hasta aproximarse
a la velocidad de la luz bueno pues
entonces beta se haría muy muy parecido
digamos a 1 y entonces gamma se haría
muy muy muy pero muy grande verdad
porque el denominador sería algo
parecido a 1 - algo parecido a 1 verdad
sería algo como 1 entre 0 verdad más o
menos en realidad está ocurriendo que el
denominador se hace cada vez más chico
verdad y si el denominador se hace cada
vez más chico entonces el factor se hace
cada vez más grande verdad de hecho si
la velocidad relativa fuera exactamente
igual a la velocidad de la luz entonces
uno estaría dividiendo entre cero y
todas
cosas sin sentido comienzan a ocurrir y
realmente te invito a que pruebes con
más números aquí por ejemplo hablamos de
una de una velocidad muy grande estamos
hablando de la mitad de la velocidad de
la luz así que podrías probar por
ejemplo con cosas más mundanas como como
la velocidad de una bala ahora en el
siguiente vídeo voy a manipular
algebraica mente todo esto para que
puedas relacionar lo que hemos visto con
lo que viene en tu libro de texto o
quizás en otras referencias